we're taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let us go next to our caller from the 2
0 2 area code who's calling today from 2
0 2 2 0 2 yes sorry that mean that is
you now we're not on speakerphone are we
not the I would but I'm in a room that I
got echo right now very good alright
well please next time fully sound treat
the room acoustically before you call
no I'm kidding go ahead question will
bite into fallen pole well he's been
falling I mean listen when he announced
he hit like 44 percent now he's down to
around 30 31 in most polls but I mean
yeah so the the window is starting to
close Elizabeth Warren is catching up in
some polls Bernie's catching up in other
polls but it's if it doesn't happen in
the next three months he'll probably end
up being the nominee yes okay I'm
guessing you don't like the sound of
that I mean yeah okay based on some live
stuff I've been looking into yeah it
doesn't look like fine and could be like
the best choice we have and yeah that's
a bad scenario how do you like what
people remember honestly my preferences
for burning and for the second
preference I guess would be a little
bored okay so the fact that the guy who
at least one is Ben is in the lead right
now that's the lights do you want now
he'll let me shave the least what about
like what about Bullock are you glad
Bullock's not in the lead problem
I don't care they don't have no chance
gotcha got it got it got it yeah
so I mean I guess also because like I
said a little more not really my first
choice here but you know what I'm
starting to wonder if buy-in actually
does into taking the polls
and you said it's Jay said you might not
but we'll see I get the feeling that
this that those super well I don't
remember how exactly it works I remember
looking up a bunch stuff but I don't I'm
liking misses home here if there a
chance that because I can just imagine
that the people in charge of doing the
DNC would be so against the Bernie
Sanders nomination that even if he ends
up looks like saying majority of the
polls and by the third Elizabeth
Warren's in second by the time the
voting starts going out that it's like
okay they'll just select born just in
general because always know you ain't
get that much majority of polls so you
know we just decided to get take her
it's it's conceivably possible but the
super delegate rules have been changed
since 2016 were super-delegates now
don't vote on the first ballot at the
DNC
so look I've still read some nightmare
scenarios where it's possible that
super-delegates could could change the
the nominee from the will of the
Democratic primary voters but if we sort
of accept what we're being told the
system's been changed so that it should
be the people deciding who the nominee
is you know you know I mean like this is
a concerning situation
mainly because Biden's Donnelly maybe
because I want Bernie to win but yeah I
just I just want to get I just want to
get somebody who knows more about this
stuff to get their thinking on this well
we will be following it closely and I I
appreciate you being engaged with it and
giving me a call alright thank you okay
thanks appreciate all right